[Musique]
les mongols voulait que nous
agenouillons de vente les brûler nos
villes tu as sans pitié à la porte
laissez nous quitter la ville le peuple
russe sombra dans le désespoir
l'ennemi semblait invincible
jusqu'à ce qu'un homme leur résistent
ils nous redonne espoir nous pouvons pas
combattre les mongols ils sont trop
nombreux
un seul de nos guerriers vos dix des
leurs c'était un vrai héros les moghols
du jet notre force réside dans le nombre
de nos guerriers
cette fois ils avaient tort le grand
khan dit que ceux qui savent nous irons
devant lui mangeront à leur fin et
boiron à leur soir je crois qu'il mourra
notre terre que si nous sommes tous pas
[Applaudissements]
oh
m
si vous le verrez pas vous mourrez tous
nous vous attendons approché tués nous
[Musique]